conservative media outlets and  politicians will often spread misleading  information  based on their supposed principles in  order to win elections at the end of the  day all they care about is winning  elections and this includes conspiracy  theories when it's convenient  cherry-picking data using completely  loaded language to evoke an emotional  response we are pro-life  wow everybody else must be against life  that sounds pretty bad we're for tax  relief  wow taxes must just simply be oppressive  taxes must be like slavery which is  quite literally what some Libertarians  say and by using this language and  manipulating The public's understanding  of the facts conservatives shape public  opinion and influence policy decisions  and voters in their favor in ways that  are completely misleading and don't  actually benefit the people that end up  voting for them